Now, for our tree egg with some engraving on the outside...
...and some little eggs in a nest on the inside.
Fill a mold with white chocolate, tip out the excess and place it upside down.
Once it's set, take off your mold then use a pastry brush...
...and brush some dark chocolate over the top.
And we want it to look rough like tree bark,...
...so we're not trying to get it smooth, just brush it over.
Once that has set, draw the outline of a heart on top using a knife...
...and then gently scrape away some of the dark chocolate...
...so that you can see the white underneath.
Don't go too deep or you're going to make a hole in your egg.
Then use your knife to scrape off the heart area...
...and it doesn't matter that it looks a bit, sort of rough...
...because that's what it would look like if you were scraping bark off a tree.
Place some chocolate into a piping bag and pipe on the initials of your choice.
Now, inside this egg I'm going to use pashmak to make a nest.
Now, pashmak is a Persian fairy floss and it's sweet with a slightly nutty flavor.
I really like it and it looks amazing.
Then add some little eggs to the inside, and what a cute little nest.
Place the top half onto a hot baking tray...
...and then add it on top of the egg...
...and you'd probably want to serve this one sitting flat in a box.